hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
today we start a new series we are
Mythbusters in four nights so put on
your white coat and grab a pink guitar
because we are scientists if you'd like
to get involved in this please check out
the description and join our discord
like this only a bunch of people did
here whenever new items are added to the
game we'll come back and we'll add to
this series as this is the first episode
we have tons to get through so let's
start busting some myths starting with
that fishing rod our first myth is
simple it's impossible to fish at the
power plant is this true or false just
for fun vote now a super easy one to
start let's drop straight in and try
here we go
yes we can I did this for ten minutes by
the way and I can confirm that all the
folly is absolutely terrible loot great
pistols low-level fish a few materials
and a rusty can for my troubles but the
myth is busted
here's our next myth is it possible to
eliminate an enemy with a fishing rod
are the fishing rod a completely
pointless weapon right well there is
more than meets the eye here our task is
to murder someone with this beast I'm
sure you realize the fishing rod can
briefly hook a teammate our enemy but
get this in your eye holes in the right
scenario we can do this using the direct
function at height a fishing rod can
indeed take someone down but gravity is
the real killer here but therefore miss
proven depending on the angle you have
four to five tails of distance with your
rod out make your own joke there the
fishing rod myths come thick and fast
now can the fishing rod grab a teammate
in the storm and yeah we tested that
course it can grab your friends without
taking any extra damage and check this
out if you've downed an enemy and
they're trying to crawl into the storm
so you can't have their loot simply drag
them back out again the next myth on our
list
giant bushes will stop fall damage at
any height this is a pretty easy one so
let's build to max height three two one
miss proven again we can take this
further do the haystacks also negate
fall damage time to go to max height
[Music]
[Music]
confirmed and the same goes for the
dumpster although that does look a
little bit more painful to London but
it's completely fine oh and something we
realized whilst doing this if you are at
max height and you jump off you can move
a total of eight tiles forward before
you land so it becomes a little easier
to hit a safe spot for example if you
see a river run and jump for it if you
see a bush a dumpster a haystack there
are so many things to break your fall
now so myth confirmed and there's one
more can the parasols negate fault
damage to and hell yeah course they can
the next myth 100 people can fit in a
single dumpster for this one we need a
very technical test we are queued up for
a solo game and met by a dumpster
we then lined up because that's what
mature people do and one by one we
started jumping in
the myth is busted oh that's a shame
only nine people fit into a dumpster
who'd have thunk it for science sake we
did the same with hay bales too and the
same result only nine people can jump
into a hiding place the next myth is a
pretty good one can we snag a fish
jumping out of water I feel like this is
a troll question so let's try and god
damn it that was stressful but I can't
confirm that no you can't and the most
annoying thing is in replay theater they
don't even jump out of the water so it
looks like you're shooting at nothing
but yeah myth busted
okay next myth waiting longer when
fishing gives you better loot this one
can't be right can it the loot must be
random but we have to test these
theories so I waited in game for five
minutes and received this hmm
I then did this four more times it was
extremely boring extremely tedious and I
was killed multiple times but it was
worth it and I can confirm once again we
have busted this myth waiting longer
does not give you better loot and
fishing one of the items you can get
from fishing is a rusty camp which leads
into our next myth a rusty can can
eliminate someone throwing the rusty can
at someone can hit them for 20 damage so
can we kill someone with it well yes and
it's quite easy actually
but can you win a game like this well if
you protect the bots that you get at the
start of the game all the way to the end
it's easy
that took me far longer to capture than
you think I'm the real bot here our next
myth can both be healed well this is a
simple one to test I took a boat under
camp fire and I set them alight and yes
I can confirm that the boat heals and so
do you if you're in or around the boat
result yes
science the next myth is it possible to
drown under water in fortnight chapter 2
another simple one to test here we go
yes easy enough you can't drown
underwater so watch what you're doing
our next myth is about the swimming
mechanic building over water is quicker
than swimming hmm how do we break this
down let's have a scientist race these
three Mythbusters will swim to the end
and high-five the referee the first
mythbuster can only use building and
running the second can only swim
straightforward but the third can use
the dolphin dive now here's the question
who will finish last it's a tough call
isn't it here's the race
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
as you can tell the dolphin dive is
crazy fast compared to standard swimming
or building we calculated the dolphin
swim to be over one-third quicker but
here's the real news standard swimming
and build running are identical in terms
of speed therefore mythbusted if you're
in the water you must unleash your inner
dolphin here's a fun one you may have
seen in my last video it is possible to
emote whilst using the ziplines check
this out
the only way to get around but the only
way to emote on a zip wire is via a
locomotion emote only traversal emotes
work but when they do work they look
incredible so the myth is confirmed you
can indeed emote whilst on the zip lines
the next myth it's impossible to rocket
right whilst carrying a player well
let's give this a go
the youths rocket right hell yeah it's
possible and the fall is certain to kill
the player ye tit but then there's the
problem of getting down maybe next time
look for a bush to London we know that
that works what's our next myth boats
block traps from hitting you so the boat
can prevent harm from traps a simple
enough test to try here we go oh oh dear
not not at all the traps will damage
both the boat and everybody on board
so myth busted we played around with
this with a little bit longer boats can
trigger traps without a player being on
board and if you're going fast enough in
that boat it's possible to pass through
the trap safely but make sure you are
going fast enough and to keep going from
this I tried planting a trap under water
but the boat did not trigger maybe it
was too far away so then we tried to
jump down and dive and swim to activate
the trap but it never activated so it
doesn't look like it works right now but
maybe in future updates traps this deep
underwater may work let's wait and see
what's next
it's possible to rocket ride the boats
missiles yeah yeah we tried this for
about 20 minutes
err no no it's not possible myth busted
you cannot
get ride bolt missiles unless I'm
missing something if you can do this
please send me evidence and now I'm
going to leave you with two myths to try
for yourself if you manage any of them
upload a video to YouTube and I'll
feature it in the next episode firstly
it's possible to eat someone onto a
rocket yeah you heard me right
you can throw a downed player or box
onto a rocket and send them flying I'd
love to see if you can do that that
really is for the hardcore though so to
break that up I have another one a boat
can climb all the way to the top of yeet
Mountain your challenge is to get this
boat up to that peak can you do it
do you accept the challenge oh and if
you're wondering why we call this yeet
mountain or Mount Yates I honestly have
no idea
yay so there we have it our first
episode of myth the bursting in for
night chapter 2 what do you think shall
we keep going with this series I'd love
to know your thoughts as always thank
you to those people have used my coal to
buy something new in the fort night shop
you guys are legands and I really
appreciate it and it helps me make
things that are a bit different like
this one I do hope you like it
anyway I'm Adam from Playstation grenade
it's been a bloody pleasure I'll see you
next time
[Music]